Gus first of all tell us how John
Callahan came to your attention your
Portland guy you're a literate guy any
one of these threads may have made this
happen um yeah I had known John as
really a local guy that you'd see racing
on the streets and his in his wheelchair
he had very bright red hair which got
brighter as he grew older he started
dying it's like it almost as bright as
your hat but I worry that's why warden
Maj Nizam in his honor and he also like
in the 80s he was he was getting more
and more recognized as a cartoonist he
was published in the weekly paper with
the Willamette week and he he appeared
on 60 minutes somewhere and I think 88
or 89 and he had written a book don't
worry he won't get far on foot that this
film is made from and that was sort of
my knowledge of him he was a Portland
celebrity of which there were not that
many and it wasn't until later when I
had worked on Good Will Hunting that
Robin Williams bought the book
independent of like myself and he
invited me to direct the film version of
it and to to oversee the writing of like
a script which we did in 1997 we made a
screenplay and gave it to Robin and his
wife Marcia who was there the production
company at Sony and just sort of never
heard anything back from them and a
couple years went by in 2002 we were
invited to make another script like have
another try at it and made a second
script with Patti Sullivan writer and
that also like just sort of went into
the system and there was never any like
okay let's start gearing up to shoot so
we never really knew what was going on
behind the executive doors and years
started going by John was very very
he was helping with the screenplay as he
was like giving us lots of information
and he was sort of on the edge of his
seat because Robin Williams is gonna
play him in a biography about himself
and he just couldn't wait and enough
years went by he said we're all gonna be
dead by the time this film's made and
then soon after that he died and that
soon after that Robin died but the book
survived still at Sony and Sony called
and said are you still interested so on
spec I wrote a script and got Joaquin on
the line to see if he'd be interested
sent in the book and we both went to
Sony with the new script and the book
and then they said no we're not
interested so but nicely they let us
take it to Amazon
there was a quirkiness and a lightness
to the music so how did you come to
think of this and what you wanted to
tell with the score well a lot of that
has to do with gus-gus doesn't like to
play things necessarily and what would
seem like the obvious way and he likes
to kind of mix things up a lot so I
already knew that from working with them
from many times that you know he may not
want to play really sentimental where it
seems like it would be and he likes to
take things from one place and try he
likes to experiment a lot which is why
it's so fun
collaborating with Gus was the book a
good guide for you did it yes did you
balance this is before and after stories
in his life
as the book tells them well no and I
think the in the book is ten chapters I
think we concentrate on only three of
those ten chapters mainly the middle
chapter about Donnie and his his working
for his own recovery the beginning we
have a little bit of his his his in the
beginning of the book he writes about
his car crash we get into the cartooning
but we don't really go into the cartoon
world which is a large part of that the
end of the book
there's this childhood we leave out so
yeah we there was it was really like
just a section of the book you two have
worked on projects together when did
this relationship click create a kind of
synergy to die for it was kind of like
one of those funny random things where
my girlfriend at the time I was 23 years
ago yeah and she knew Gus and that was
Caroline Thompson the writer and she
came over one day said you know would I
just met where did you guys where did
you guys meet I forget she came back we
had the same agent John Brown he had the
same age and said would you like like to
meet him I go yeah [ __ ] yeah you know I
was a huge fan of Drugstore Cowboy so I
say whatever he's doing I'd love to do
it and so to die for we just jumped in
and started doing it and how was it an
awkward collaboration or did you click
at once that one was funny you just
right well I mean I I thought that in my
the only time that I'd worked with the
composer up into that point like a an
official composer because Katie Lange
did even cowgirls get the blues elliot
goldenthal had done Drugstore Cowboy but
sort of from New York so from afar and
so I thought he'd just he what you do is
you just send the cut to the composer
and they just send back the the
composition the composed film and I was
basically trying to do that I was
sending you the VHS and said yeah how
does that work tell us when you're done
i meanwhile was kind of in the other
side you know at that was probably I've
done 30 or 40 films and I was used to
like the director will you know
everything has to come from them so I
just kept sending him some saying well
which you have to choose he goes well I
don't know what do you remember going
you were living in Topanga so I would go
to Topanga and listen to the choices she
was a a B C or D and then and choose C
and then you go like well you should
listen to B again
once you do this when you when you sit
down to edit and you have so many
choices before you in telling this story
what what was it you didn't want us to
know about John or at least not to
express in the film well I mean there
was lots of ways to kind of approach the
story of about of a guy who was a great
success in his cartooning and one of
them was the story of that success and
like the the step by step advances he
made in the cartooning world the
publishing world and there was a lot of
mentorship with Sam gross a cartoonists
who was editor for National Lampoon and
he was New Yorker contributor people
like that were like sort of saying like
never give away your originals you know
like always make copies or like always
giving like a backup or could let them
send four at a time all these rules that
of cartooning that we could have gotten
into the machinations of that also I
think we could have gotten into the
controversy that he was causing because
nobody really knew that the creator of
his cartoons was a quadriplegic himself
and that his jokes were often about
disabilities and so he would get hate
mail and he would get angry letters that
he sort of just enjoyed but didn't
really respond you know didn't try and
explain anything to the readers and we
didn't get in to that side of it either
these were all in my early outlines
these sections for Joaquin Phoenix who
came to this much later obviously than
you or Robin Williams who've been
immersed in it for so long how did he
prepare to be callahan to make himself
into this guy this is the kind of
question that walking and we'd like
started looking at the floor
but I can answer for him see he he is
sort of he does I think even when he
read the book he's are probably already
thinking about you know the
possibilities so he's getting inspired
and then as he gets closer I mean he had
a book that was marked in like four
different colors and like written things
written in the margins and extra pages
pasted in that he lost on this set one
day which was shocking because so much
stuff was in it I thought oh can he can
continue to work without this Bible that
he had created so he's spending enough
time to actually create this crazy
looking version of the book no.8 he
found it laughing it was probably in a
car or something like that but um we did
find it
it's very Calahan kind of thing to do
yeah and he he did have me go through
every page of the book with him and we
would talk for about 10 minutes or more
or 15 minutes about on each page or
sometimes longer and I think that took
about two weeks so it was like him
making sure that what he was gonna do
was gonna fit into what you wanted to be
happening and he wanted to like hear it
very clearly like what was supposed to
be happening in each scene so he knew
the parameters of where he should go
which was very good luck Danny like
multiple choice like I go this way or
that way but no we just to make sure
that he wasn't gonna end up like in a
moment where he didn't understand what
was supposed to be happening
thank you both will you please thank the
pen thank you
[Applause]